13h  heure locale à Baïkonour,
nous suivons l'heure exacte du lancement
ce matin à 5 h 30 1 et 52 secondes,
heure centrale, nous avons une vue en direct de
la fusée Soyouz sur le site une
rampe de lancement à Baïkonour l'équipe de contrôleurs de lancement
surveille  sur tous les
systèmes à bord de la fusée qui est maintenant
entièrement alimentée en carburant et prête à être lancée, aucun
problème n'a été détecté tout au long de la
journée jusqu'à présent, qui a commencé avec le chargement de carburant et d'
oxydant vers 127 heures, heure centrale
, ce matin ou 127 heures.  Lundi
après-midi, hors du site de lancement à
Baïkonour, il est terminé environ deux heures
plus tard, les systèmes de contrôle des lanceurs
ont été préparés et les gyroscopes
viennent d'être activés bonjour d'ici dans
la salle de contrôle de vol de la Station spatiale internationale
au Johnson Space Center
ici à Houston Texas
derrière  moi ce sont les équipes du
quart d'orbite 1 ce matin dans la salle de contrôle
ici qui surveillent les systèmes de la
Station Spatiale Internationale elle-même et
bien sûr l'équipage de l'expédition 57 à
bord de la Station Spatiale Internationale
sur votre écran juste là vous pouvez voir
le directeur de vol  Chris Edelen à la tête des
équipes a tenté le lancement depuis ici à
Mission Control Houston il y a quelques
minutes à peine, vous entendrez les voix
de Brandon Lloyd et Andreas Mogensen,
ce sont les Capcom qui
communiquent aujourd'hui avec l'équipage à bord de la
Station spatiale internationale.  de l'
expédition 57 actuellement à bord de l'
astronaute de la NASA Serena sur et le chancelier
Alexander Gerst
de l'Union européenne  Agence spatiale le
commandant de l'expédition 57 et Sergei
Prokofiev de Rose cosmos aujourd'hui les
équipes suivent le lancement de l'astronaute de la
NASA et McLane l'
astronaute de l'Agence spatiale canadienne David saint-jacques et
le cosmonaute russe et commandant de Soyouz
Oleg Kononenko cet équipage est le premier à se
lancer à bord d'un Soyouz  fusée depuis le
précédent événement d'abandon du lancement qui
s'est produit le 11 octobre de cette
année, l'atterrissage balistique réussi
qui a suivi a ramené Nick Hague de la NASA
et le cosmonaute Alexei Keenan en toute sécurité
sur terre indemnes aujourd'hui, mais les
trois membres de cet équipage Soyouz MS 11
sont sur le point de commencer  un
vol Orbitz prévu vers la Station spatiale internationale
avec un amarrage prévu
environ six heures après le lancement 11
h 36, heure centrale 23 h 36  à
Baïkonour, où leurs collègues, amis
et famille, regarderont les événements
se dérouler à ce moment-là, le Soyouz et ce
11 vaisseau spatial s'amarreront avec le
module poisk au port de l'espace
faisant face au côté du segment russe de
la station spatiale, vous pouvez voir quatre
visiter des véhicules déjà là ou alors
'oui, ms levin nous amarrera à nouveau
six heures après le lancement ce matin, l'
équipage rejoindra les résidents actuels de la station à
bord, fournissant sûrement un
peu de soulagement en amenant la station à
une capacité complète, ne serait-ce que pour
quelques semaines  les membres actuels de l'équipage de la station
sont à nouveau l'astronaute de la nasa serena
on et le chancelier cosmonaute russe et
commandant soyuz sergei prokofiev
représentant ross cosmos et ISA
l'astronaute de l'agence spatiale européenne et
actuel commandant de la
station spatiale internationale Alexander Gerst ils
sont arrivés à la station à bord du Soyuz
MSO neuf plus tôt  cette année, en juin, ces
trois ont maintenu toutes les
opérations de la station pour expediti  sur 57 et
devraient revenir sur Terre bientôt le
19 décembre u.s.  heure du 20 décembre
Kazakhstan heure ici à Houston l'équipe
de Mission Control surveillera
le lancement d'aujourd'hui en obtenant des mises à jour du
directeur de vol et de ses homologues russes
à la tête des équipes aujourd'hui Chris
Edelen directeur de vol là-
bas en bas de l'écran sera sur console
pour le lancement de Soyouz  et à nouveau
Brandon Lloyd et Andreas Mogensen de Capcom
pendant la montée en orbite de Soyuz, le suivi
et la télémétrie sont reliés aux stations au sol le
long de la trajectoire de vol et sont
acheminés vers le centre de contrôle de mission russe
juste à l'extérieur de Moscou dans la
ville de Korolev pendant que nous attendons  les
événements pour démarrer et tout au
long de la couverture de la journée, nous répondrons
aux questions sur le lancement de Soyouz à partir
des médias sociaux si vous avez des questions auxquelles vous
aimeriez avoir une réponse lors de l'émission d'aujourd'hui,
allez-y et demandez-nous sur Twitter en utilisant le
hashtag ask NASA
you '  je regarde le
centre de contrôle de mission là-bas à Korolev,
c'est le centre de contrôle de mission russe
qui cherche également  lors du lancement d'aujourd'hui
ainsi qu'ils peuvent lancer le centre de
contrôle à Baïkonour lors du lancement aujourd'hui, la
NASA et McLane et l'
astronaute de l'Agence spatiale canadienne David saint-
jacques célébreront leur premier voyage
dans l'espace alors que cela marquera le
quatrième vol spatial pour le cosmonaute et
soyuz ms  xi commandant oleg kononenko
ayant été sélectionné par la NASA en
2013, l'astronaute et colonel de l'armée et
McLane ont déclaré qu'elle se sentait très préparée pour
elle un vol spatial entièrement féminin, elle sera
la première de la classe de 2013 à
voler vers la Station spatiale internationale dont
elle est originaire  Spokane
Washington McLane est titulaire d'un baccalauréat en
sciences et en génie mécanique et aéronautique
de West Point. Elle a
poursuivi ses études en Angleterre en tant que
boursière Marshall en obtenant deux
maîtrises en sciences, l'une
en génie aérospatial et l'autre en
relations internationales.
plus
de deux mille heures de vol enregistrées sur
20 avions rotatifs différents  et
McLane à voilure fixe a été sélectionné
comme astronaute dans le cadre de la 21e
classe d'astronautes en 2013 et a terminé deux
ans de formation de candidat astronaute en
juillet 2015, cette formation hautement spécialisée
comprend une formation intensive
dans les systèmes de la station spatiale internationale sorties dans l'espace
formation en langue russe
robotique t  -38 entraînement en vol, survie dans l'eau et dans la
nature et bien plus encore
et maintenant, pendant que nous comptons sur un lancement
ce matin, apprenons un peu plus
sur la NASA et McLane et comment elle est
sortie de la rampe de lancement et comment elle est arrivée à
la rampe de lancement au fait  du
terrain de rugby,
donc la première fois que j'ai joué au rugby, j'avais en
fait 18 ans, c'était l'année avant d'
aller à West Point et je
traversais le campus de l'université Gonzaga et
j'ai vu un groupe de personnes pratiquer un sport
qui ne ressemblait à rien de ce que je '  J'ai vu qu'il y
avait beaucoup de tacles, je n'arrivais pas à
comprendre ce qui se passait et l'un d'eux
m'a demandé si j'étais intéressé à l'
essayer et le lendemain, j'ai
J'ai commencé mon premier match de rugby que j'avais joué
tout au long de mon séjour à West Point,
puis lorsque j'étais boursier Marshall, j'ai eu la
chance d'étudier en
Angleterre et là, j'ai commencé à jouer à un
niveau supérieur en 2004. J'ai été élu
aux États-Unis.  équipe nationale, j'ai eu la chance
de jouer beaucoup au rugby, puis j'ai aussi
entraîné un peu juste avant d'aller
à l'école de pilotage d'essai mon dernier week-end à
jouer au rugby était le week-end avant de
découvrir qu'il était devenu astronaute, donc le
rugby m'a étonnamment aidé  beaucoup en
tant qu'astronaute et quand je m'entraîne dans
la combinaison spatiale dans l'EMU et que nous
travaillons dans notre grande piscine, le
laboratoire de flottabilité neutre sous l'eau, nous
sommes là-dessous pendant six heures d'affilée et
vous travaillez vraiment vous-même pour  épuisement physique et
mental la seule autre fois
où j'ai atteint ce point d'épuisement
est la 60e minute d'un match de rugby lorsque
votre corps est si fatigué physiquement que
vous ne pouvez pas abandonner mentalement vous devez en fait
penser aux choses plus
délibérément avec plus  clarté parce que
vous êtes plus sujet aux erreurs et que ce sont
les gens qui peuvent surmonter ce
physique et continuer avec le joueur
qui gagne les deux matchs de rugby et ils
se retrouvent avec succès dans
l'espace
je suis anne mccla  et je suis un astronaute
vous
[Musique]
qui parlait un peu de l'
astronaute de la NASA et du lancement de McClane ce
matin, vous pouvez suivre son voyage à
la poignée Astro animal de retour à Baïkonour,
vous jetez à nouveau un coup d'œil au
centre de contrôle de mission à  Korolyov
où les contrôleurs de vol travaillent là-bas
avec les contrôleurs de vol ici dans
la salle de contrôle de vol de la Station spatiale internationale
surveillant le lancement d'aujourd'hui,
mais bien sûr de retour à Baïkonour, McClane
a rejoint la capsule aujourd'hui par
l'ingénieur astronaute de l'Agence spatiale canadienne
et le dr.  David saint-jacques disant que Jog
sera le premier astronaute de l'
Agence spatiale canadienne à s'envoler dans l'espace en
six ans suite à la mission de Chris
Hadfield et ce sont de grosses chaussures à remplir
tombant sur les épaules de géants
avant moi lors des précédents astronautes peuvent manger
donc  c'est un grand privilège de
lire l'honneur et aussi une grande source d'
humilité et de responsabilité d'être le
prochain à représenter ma fière
nation là-bas saint-jacques a été sélectionné pour le
service en mai 2009 et a déménagé à
Houston comme l'un des 14 membres du  20e
classe d'astronautes de la NASA avant de
devenir astronaute, même Jacques était
médecin et co-chef de la médecine dans un
centre de santé desservant une communauté inuite
sur la baie d'Hudson, il a également travaillé comme
professeur auxiliaire à la
faculté de médecine clinique et à l'Université McGill.
international saint-jacques a
commencé sa carrière en tant qu'ingénieur biomédical
et a développé des
systèmes d'optique adaptative et d'infer ama tree pour des
télescopes au Japon et  Hawaï, son
expérience comprend également des
travaux d'ingénierie en Hongrie et une formation médicale au
Liban et au Guatemala maintenant en tant
qu'astronaute prêt à effectuer son premier
vol
spatial.  Le voyage de Jaques a été soutenu
tout au long du parcours par sa femme et ses trois jeunes
enfants qui
complètent et commandent l'équipage Soyouz NS
onze est le cosmonaute russe et
vétéran des vols spatiaux Oleg Kononenko, il
est né en charge de Turk mania et
est diplômé de l'Institut d'aviation de Kharkov
en 1988 en tant que
ingénieur en mécanique, il a ensuite travaillé au
bureau central de conception du centre national de
recherche et de développement et de production de
fusées et d'espace à Samara en
Russie le 29 mars 1996, il a été désigné
comme candidat cosmonaute d'essai
Kononenko a décollé dans l'espace pour la première
fois  en avril 2008 à bord du soyuz
tma 12, il suivra cela avec deux
autres voyages avant ce lancement, enregistrant
un total de 533 jours dans l'espace avec trois sorties dans l'espace
jusqu'à présent, son vol le plus récent
a eu lieu en juillet 2015 où il a servi en tant que
membre  de l'équipage de l'expédition 44 et 45
cette année, il a effectué des tâches de sauvegarde
pour les deux équipages Soyouz précédents, nous sommes
maintenant à moins de 50 minutes de la
la  Unch de l'équipage de l'expédition 58 à la
Station spatiale internationale cette mission se
lance sous le côté d'appel et Tory's
choisi par BTS utilisera le commandant MS 11
Antares comme l'étoile la plus brillante de la
constellation du scorpion se
distingue dans le ciel nocturne par son
ton rougeâtre et est parfois
confondu avec Mars comme toujours en l'honneur de leur
mission l'équipage soyuz ms 11 a un
patch officiel cette mission l'imagerie
représente la station spatiale internationale
ouvrant la voie à la future
exploration de l'espace lointain vous pouvez voir le Soyouz se
diriger vers la station spatiale l'horizon
coupant à travers  le milieu et la
forme rouge ressemblant au symbole du
cosmos Rose véhiculant tous les
objectifs d'exploration futurs du programme et la
coopération internationale nécessaire pour les
accomplir dans le respect d'une autre
tradition installée et le
tableau de bord Soyouz pendant la croisière en
cabine les activités de préparation avant le lancement
la semaine dernière, nos indicateurs zéro-g et
McLane nous dit que son fils a choisi un ba  par
dragon pour l'accompagner dans le voyage ce
dragon est
maintenant étreint par un
elfe de Noël surprise spécial vacances elfe de Noël
quant à Saint Jacque il a ses enfants
à remercier pour son indicateur ils ont décidé
de l'envoyer dans l'espace avec leur
jouet [ __ ] laveur préféré partagé si nous  'pouvez
observer ces jouets de près pendant l'
ascension de Soyouz nous pourrons les voir flotter
lorsque la capsule atteindra l'apesanteur
malgré elle ma fouine qu'est-ce que le
courant ils deviendront beaucoup plus frais 8
1 2 est l'événement en cours ou un
café spécial 8 1  2
Simar one est activé racing
recommandé pour les ingénieurs de zoo et de vol il
nous reste encore 40 minutes
privées et tante iris si vous le souhaitez,
vous pouvez simplement aller comment jouer votre musique
[Musique]
vous obtenez un look en direct  à l'engin soyuz
ms 11, vous pouvez voir les
tours à portique à clapet toujours autour du château
maintenant nous recevons un b-roll de
plus tôt dans la journée l'équipage s'est réveillé vers
20h30 13h00.  Central Time soir
dimanche soir 08h31 heure locale à
Baïkonour c'est neuf heures avant le
lancement les membres de l'équipage ont ensuite participé
aux dernières activités de pré-lancement avant de
partir pour la rampe de lancement trois
membres de l'équipage ont observé une longue
tradition de dédicace des portes  de
l'hôtel des cosmonautes à Baïkonour
Kazakhstan
et juste après le prêtre de bénédiction
vers 23h30.  Heure centrale le dimanche
soir 11h30 Lundi matin à
Baïkonour, l'équipage a quitté l'
hôtel des cosmonautes et à bord du bus pour le trajet
vers l'installation d'intégration et SUDEP qui
est en train de construire à 54 au cosmodrome de Baïkonour
[Musique]
êtes-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour beaucoup d'amis, de famille et de
médias qui ont rejoint c'est la dernière fois
qu'ils approchent cela de près et
personnellement des trois astronautes doppler pour
se rendre à la Station spatiale internationale vers laquelle
ils se sont rendus  construire
deux 54 de leurs médias et amis et
famille peuvent se rejoindre à nouveau cette fois
séparés par un panneau de verre à leur
arrivée chaque membre d'équipage a subi
des examens médicaux finaux, puis ils se sont adaptés à
ce que vous voyez ici le soi-disant
lancement et entrée supposent  les combinaisons ont
ensuite été pressurisées pour assurer l'intégrité
de leurs sceaux
[Musique]
activités de tournage à Southie sur le
chrome central fois quatre heures et demie
avant le lancement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Appl  ause]
prenant ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après la série d'activités, le trio
se déplace dans une pièce qu'il regarde maintenant
vers les amis et la famille, vous pouvez les
voir maintenant derrière un panneau de  verre après
les activités de combinaison c'est là
qu'ils commencent le test de pression les combinaisons
sont les trois astronautes qui entrent dans une
maquette de l'un des sièges du
véhicule Soyouz et sont entièrement sous pression pour
vérifier l'intégrité du sceau de la
combinaison elle-même
une fois que les membres de l'équipage ont vérifié que la
combinaison n'a pas de fuites, ils
subissent ces vérifications de fuites, ils ont la
possibilité d'aller jusqu'à l'un des
microphones devant la piscine n'ont pas
eu les derniers instants pour discuter
avec  leurs familles parce que l'Ala
kononenko et ici vous voyez des suppressions et
Ja discutant à nouveau avec sa famille trois
enfants et sa femme et un propre maintenant dans le
fauteuil subissant sa dernière série de
contrôles de pression cela a de nouveau commencé vers
1h00 heure centrale ce matin 1
après-midi  à Baïkonour
[Musique]
[Musique] se
marier
et ce n'est pas seulement beaucoup de carburant qui
vous soulève, c'est et vraiment un cœur qui bat
[Musique]
[Rires]
toi  je viens de voir l'
astronaute de l'Agence spatiale européenne Luca parmitano faisant partie de l'
équipage de secours bon lancement ce matin
je suis heureux de voir que vous
êtes prêts à vous aider
à bord de la station spatiale passez un bon moment à
bord de la station spatiale profitez de votre temps
vous serez très  occupé trouvez un peu de
temps supplémentaire pour vous amuser prenez soin de
vous et prenez soin de la
station spatiale pour nous je pense que vous avez travaillé
très dur pour arriver là où vous en êtes
une phase très sérieuse de l'opération
mais n'oubliez pas que vous êtes aussi là pour  amusez-
vous, les yeux du monde seront sur
vous pour en profiter autant que vous venez de voir
certains des gestionnaires de Rose cosmos et de la
NASA donner quelques derniers commentaires c'est la
dernière chance d'Atlantis de le faire derrière la
vitre de protection avant qu'ils ne fassent leur
chemin  sur la rampe de lancement un vif mais
m  après-midi possible là-bas à Baïkonour
environ 24 degrés Fahrenheit
vers 2h30 heure centrale 14h30.
à Baïkonour, ils se sont rendus du
bâtiment au 54 jusqu'à la rampe de
lancement sur le site 1 du cosmodrome dans l'
après-midi là-bas à Baïkonour ce matin
ici aux États-Unis, ce trajet prend environ
25 minutes,
ils écrivent de la rampe vers 256 heures du matin,
heure centrale  256 h  là-bas à Baïkonour,
les mêmes membres du site 254 les
rencontrent ici au pad et les
escortent jusqu'aux escaliers qui les amènent à la
capsule y prendront un ascenseur pour
monter les tours de service du portique à clapet
vous regardez certains des derniers
moments  la dernière vague avant
qu'ils ne montent dans l'ascenseur
et dans la capsule,
puis il y a à nouveau ce trajet en ascenseur
qui monte jusqu'au sommet
où la capsule Soyouz est sur le point d'
avoir une vue en direct maintenant des
tours de service du portique à clapet de la capsule Soyouz
qui  vous venez de les voir remonter il y a à peine
deux heures environ, maintenant qu'ils sont rétractés,
nous sommes maintenant à un peu plus de 31 minutes avant le
lancement prévu à nouveau à 5 h 31.
Heure centrale 5 h 31.  heure locale à
Baïkonour, nous savons déjà que le lancement d'aujourd'hui
sera le tout premier voyage dans l'
espace pour la NASA et McLane, mais il
y a quelques choses à son sujet que vous
n'auriez probablement pas deviné, voyons
ce que cela va bien une chose que la plupart des
gens  Je ne sais pas pour moi, c'est que je
voulais être astronaute depuis que j'avais
trois ans, c'est là que j'ai dit pour la première fois à
ma mère que je voulais être astronaute
quand je suis allé à l'école maternelle, je lui ai dit
que j'allais à l'école  apprendre à être
astronaute et quand j'étais à la maternelle
j'ai écrit mon premier livre très mal écrit
sur aller dans l'espace sur le
véhicule Soyouz quand j'étais en sixième j'ai eu
une fête d'anniversaire et j'ai demandé à
chacun de mes amis un
calculatrice pour mon anniversaire et je n'ai pas
dit à mes parents parce que j'étais trop
gêné mais j'ai eu beaucoup de
calculatrices et j'étais super ringard à
ce sujet mais l'une des choses que j'ai apprises
c'est que tu sais que tu dois juste être toi-même
je voulais  un tas de calculatrices j'ai eu un
bu  quelques calculatrices et ça allait
j'étais un énorme nerd à l'époque et je suis toujours un
total nerd maintenant mais bon les nerds peuvent aller
dans l'espace une autre chose que la plupart des gens ne
savent pas à mon sujet, c'est que j'ai bien joué au
rugby peut-être si vous '  Je suis proche de moi, vous le
savez probablement parce que je suis un
peu fou de rugby et la dernière fois
que j'ai joué, c'était environ une semaine avant d'
être sélectionné ici à la NASA. J'ai joué
en Premiership anglaise en Angleterre et
je suis revenu et je  joué aux états-unis
l'équipe nationale une des choses que j'ai
apprise sur moi-même en jouant au rugby alors
j'applique chaque jour c'est quand tu
penses que tu as tout donné et que
tu n'as plus rien à donner physiquement
et mentalement tu as une réserve dans laquelle tu
peux puiser et tu peux  continuez,
j'étais pilote d'hélicoptère dans l'armée, j'ai
piloté des hélicoptères pendant environ dix ans
avant de devenir pilote d'essai et l'une
des choses que j'ai apprises à piloter des
hélicoptères, c'est que quand quelque chose semble
vraiment risqué de l'extérieur, les
gens qui le font  à l'intérieur,
ce ne sont pas des preneurs de risques professionnels, mais
ce sont probablement des atténuateurs de risques professionnels.
Un été, j'ai regardé le
film Top Gun tellement de fois probablement
trois fois par jour pendant quelques mois
que mon frère a finalement
sorti la cassette de la VHS  et l'a cassé sur sa jambe
pour que je ne puisse plus jamais le regarder j'étais
absolument dévasté et donc peut-être que c'est en
partie de sa faute si je dois aller
vivre ce rêve en tant que pilote militaire mais
vous k  maintenant, vous ne savez jamais d'où vous
allez vous inspirer et si vous êtes
bien inspiré, continuez à le faire
même si votre frère dit de ne pas
[Musique
] c'était un peu à propos de la NASA et de
McLain qui est au sommet du Soyouz
véhicule en ce moment, vous pouvez voir à partir de
cette prise de vue en direct sur le site l'un des
cosmodromes de Baïkonour les tours à portique à clapet
entièrement rétractées, vous pouvez voir des
deux côtés de l'écran les
tours vertes complètement horizontales à ce
stade l'un des nombreux jalons qui
suivront  jusqu'au lancement dans seulement 28
minutes à partir de maintenant, je suis Gary Jordan ici dans
la salle de contrôle de vol de la Station spatiale internationale
au Johnson Space
Center à Houston, les équipes du Texas derrière
moi surveillent le lancement d'aujourd'hui sont prêtes pour le
lancement et communiquent avec les
équipes de Mission  Contrôlez Moscou pour
surveiller le lancement en toute sécurité de nos trois
astronautes aujourd'hui, nous répondrons aux
questions en direct tout au long de l'émission d'aujourd'hui en
utilisant le hashtag ask NASA sur
Twitter, nous avons quelques qu  Les propositions arrivent,
nous en prendrons une tout de suite celle-ci
vient de trace qui demande combien d'
astronautes la Station Spatiale Internationale peut
accueillir en même temps
bien généralement nous regardons environ six
astronautes et c'est ce que nous allons
stocker aujourd'hui  six astronautes au total
sur la Station spatiale internationale trois à
bord en ce moment trois en route
il s'agit d'une période de transfert normale
pour la Station spatiale internationale, mais
elle peut accueillir bien plus que cela,
le record que nous avons remonte
en fait à 2009 dans le cadre de STS  119 il y avait 13
personnes à bord de la Station spatiale internationale
pour une courte période de temps
encore vous regardez la couverture en direct
du lancement de l'astronaute de la NASA et McLane de
l'Agence spatiale canadienne David
saint-jacques et oleg kononenko de ros
cosmos - l'International  La station spatiale
se rapproche maintenant, les
composants des structures de service de la rampe de lancement ont
déjà été abaissés et les
tours à portique à clapet ont été rétractées  en
préparation du décollage de la combinaison, des
contrôles d'étanchéité sont à nouveau en cours cette
fois à l'intérieur de la cabine Soyouz et le
système d'évacuation d'urgence a été armé
cette tour d'évacuation se déclencherait en
cas de problème lors du lancement le
système est conçu pour tirer le
vaisseau spatial et  l'équipage se dégage du
booster permettant à la capsule Soyouz de
parachuter vers un atterrissage en toute sécurité en cas
d'urgence lors du lancement ou des
premières étapes de la montée en orbite à mesure que nous
nous rapprochons du lancement, vous verrez plusieurs
autres événements se dérouler en quatre minutes
avant le lancement, la
purge d'azote de la chambre de combustion commence une équipe en t-moins
2 minutes 45 secondes la
pressurisation du réservoir de propulseur d'appoint a lieu l'
événement se poursuit alors que la première
tour ombilicale est rétractée à t-moins 35 secondes
et la seconde à t-moins 15 a  t-moins
12, la commande de lancement est émise,
culminant avec le lancement du vaisseau spatial Soyouz alors
que le compte à rebours
atteint zéro à 5 h 31 et 52
secondes. Heure centrale 5:  30152 h
heure locale à Baïkonour pendant la
montée en orbite, le suivi et la télémétrie
du véhicule Soyouz sont en liaison descendante vers
les stations au sol le long de la
trajectoire de vol et sont acheminés vers le bloc de contrôle de lancement
près de la rampe de lancement à
Baïkonour, puis vers le
centre de contrôle de mission russe  à l'extérieur de Moscou à nouveau
à Korolev, ils avaient l'opinion que vous
dites en ce moment et ce vol est
contrôlé depuis Baïkonour jusqu'à l'
arrêt du moteur du troisième étage lors
de la transition vers le
centre de contrôle de vol russe
[Musique]
quelques secondes après que le Soyouz ait atteint  orbite
le système de commande et de contrôle des véhicules
sera activé les commandes informatiques stockées
déploieront
les antennes de navigation et de communication et les panneaux
solaires seront déployés pour collecter l'énergie
à utiliser par les batteries embarquées
quelques étapes après le lancement bien sûr la
première étape s'arrêtera à une minute 58
puis que d'abord l'étage central continue en
tant que deuxième étage jusqu'au
largage du carénage et au deuxième largage du carénage
n quelques minutes plus tard, puis un
arrêt du deuxième étage et un largage après celui
qui allume le troisième étage, il s'agit d'un
feu chaud où le troisième étage est allumé
avant la séparation de cette
partie du deuxième étage du profil d'
ascension le profil d'ascension normal et le troisième étage
l'atterrissage et la séparation des engins spatiaux
commencent à huit minutes 45 secondes jusqu'à
une insertion orbitale préliminaire un peu
moins de neuf minutes après que le Soyouz
atteigne à nouveau l'orbite le
système de commande et de contrôle des véhicules sera activé
les commandes informatiques stockées déploieront
les antennes de navigation et de communication
et les panneaux solaires seront déployés  pour
collecter l'énergie à utiliser par les
batteries embarquées pour générer de l'électricité pour
les systèmes Soyouz les premières antennes
seront déployées bien que là où
se produisent les antennes de rendez-vous et d'amarrage
qui seront utilisées pour fournir des informations automatiques sur la
portée et le taux de fermeture sur
l'approche finale du Soyouz  pour
s'amarrer avec le module poisk à nouveau sur
l'espace faisant face  côté de la
Station spatiale internationale après avoir
atteint l'orbite, l'équipage supervisera la
séquence d'activation programmée d'une
variété de systèmes juste avant que le
vaisseau spatial ne passe hors de portée des
stations au sol russes, ces systèmes
incluent le système d'alimentation électrique du vaisseau spatial, son
système de communication radio
et la mission critique  système de contrôle de mouvement
pendant la première orbite du vol d'aujourd'hui,
les Suédois exécuteront automatiquement
les deux premières des nombreuses
brûlures d'ajustement orbital prévues alors que le
véhicule affine son chemin vers la Station spatiale internationale
[Musique]
obtenant à nouveau des vues en direct du véhicule Soyouz
nous '  suivre un lancement à 5 h 31,
heure centrale aujourd'hui, cela survient juste
avant le coucher du soleil à Baïkonour, désormais
prévu à 18 h ou 16 h.  heure locale là-
bas, vous verrez que le ciel se rapproche un peu de
ces couleurs de coucher de soleil comme vous
pouvez même le voir en ce moment un peu moins de 22
minutes après le lancement, vous pouvez voir les
tours ombilicales là-bas à gauche
du véhicule, elles seront rétractées quelques
secondes  avant le décollage, cette première
tour ombilicale vers le haut du
véhicule au-dessus de la pelouse, le carénage qui
recouvre actuellement le véhicule Soyouz
sera à nouveau rétracté 35 secondes
avant le lancement
et cette première tour ombilicale que vous
pouvez voir en quelque sorte vers le bas de
cela  en fait près du premier étage
du véhicule, cet étage central sera
rétracté juste 15 secondes avant le
décollage
[Musique]
Andras c'est Vikon ou leur rougeur est de
15 minutes de copie afin que vous puissiez le réactiver c'est de
la vapeur que vous  'vois du
véhicule est une ventilation normale d'
oxygène  ist systèmes modernisés ou série ms
du véhicule pourquoi il s'appelle MS 11
ce matin
la fusée Soyouz mesure 162 pieds de haut
et pèse environ six cent quatre-vingt
mille livres se compose du vaisseau spatial Soyouz M
s 11 à l'intérieur du
carénage protecteur que vous pouvez voir là-bas à  le haut
et le propulseur Soyouz FG à trois étages
ci-dessous, comme vous pouvez voir la tour d'évacuation
de cette vue sur le pad du
site, un vaisseau spatial a été accouplé à son
propulseur et les trois moteurs principaux ont été
réunis la semaine dernière, la
fusée entière a commencé son  Trek vers la rampe de lancement
juste après 7h00, heure de Baïkonour
samedi, arrivant moins de deux heures
plus tard où il a été relevé à sa
position verticale pour les derniers
préparatifs de pré-lancement. Le vaisseau spatial de SWE
avec ses trois membres d'équipage à bord se
trouve bien au-dessus des trois  étages du
propulseur Soyouz qui utilise du kérosène et
de l'oxygène liquide comme propulseur
le premier étage de la fusée a quatre
moteurs liquides attachés sur le côté
du véhicule principal  chacun brûlera pendant
environ une minute et 58 secondes avant de
tomber ces quatre moteurs fonctionnent
en tandem avec le moteur central ce moteur principal
sert également de deuxième étage
et continue de brûler jusqu'à quatre minutes
et 57 secondes dans le vol là vous
pouvez voir  la tour d'évacuation étant
larguée avant que ces quatre
propulseurs à sangle ne s'envolent à nouveau ce moteur principal
sert de deuxième étage le carénage ou
le carénage tout en haut est
largué et expose le
véhicule Soyouz au vide de l'espace ce
que vous voyez est  la mise en scène à chaud du
troisième étage se déclenche juste avant que les secondes réelles du
deuxième étage séparé ne soient
séparées car le troisième étage a un
seul moteur qui s'enflammera juste
avant que cette séparation l'aide à le
repousser et brûlera pendant environ huit
minutes jusqu'à huit  minutes 45
secondes après le début du vol à ce moment-là,
les sols Soyouz seront dans son
orbite préliminaire Soyouz un vaisseau spatial 11
doit s'amarrer au
complexe en orbite l  Après aujourd'hui, après avoir terminé une
voie rapide pour le rendez-vous en orbite, le rendez-vous
prévu d'une journée se
terminera par un amarrage au
module
poisk de la
Station spatiale internationale
.  36h00
heure centrale ce matin 23h36  à
Baïkonour tandis que des dignitaires russes et américains
invités et leur famille
regarderont les événements se dérouler depuis un hôtel
non loin du site de lancement au
Kazakhstan,
il s'agit encore une fois d'un aperçu en direct de la
rampe de lancement en ce moment au sommet de la fusée et
à l'intérieur du Soyouz M s 11  les vaisseaux spatiaux sont à nouveau ceux de la
NASA et McLean David
saint-jacques de l'Agence spatiale canadienne
et Oleg Kononenko de Rose cosmos
maintenant à moins de 16 minutes du lancement un
[Musique] un
peu plus sur le vaisseau spatial Soyouz,
il est composé de trois modules de 23
pieds et 1/2 pieds de long et  pèse quinze
mille sept cents livres le
module de descente au milieu est situé
au milieu du véhicule Soyouz
contient des sièges personnalisés pour les
membres d'équipage lors de l'entrée et de l'atterrissage du lancement
et contient toutes les commandes et
affichages nécessaires au vol il
contient également des systèmes de survie  les batteries
pour la rentrée et l'atterrissage et les
parachutes et les moteurs de fusée à atterrissage en douceur
qui ralentissent le Soyouz
avant l'atterrissage lorsque le  Soyouz atterrit au
Kazakhstan, il y a huit
propulseurs au peroxyde d'hydrogène situés sur le module
qui sont utilisés pour contrôler l'
orientation ou l'attitude de l'engin spatial
pendant la descente jusqu'au
déploiement du parachute.
Il dispose également d'
un système de navigation et de contrôle de guidage pour manœuvrer le véhicule
pendant la phase de descente de la mission.
le module de descente pèse plus de 6 000
livres avec un volume habitable de 141
pieds cubes environ 110 livres de
charge utile peuvent être renvoyés sur terre dans ce
module le module de descente est la seule
partie de ces trois que vous avez vu
plus tôt qui survit au retour sur
terre vous êtes  voir la trappe ouverte vers
la partie supérieure c'est le
module orbital relie le module de descente via une
trappe pressurisée c'est là que l'équipage
a une petite quantité d'espace pour se
déplacer pendant le vol vers la
station spatiale internationale comme un volume
de 230 pieds cubes  avec une
trappe de mécanisme d'amarrage et une antenne de rendez-vous
située à l'extrémité avant, le
mécanisme d'amarrage est utilisé  pour s'amarrer à la
station spatiale et l'écoutille permet l'entrée dans
le complexe orbital
l'antenne de rendez-vous est utilisée par le
système d'amarrage automatisé qui utilise le
radar pour manœuvrer vers la station
pour s'amarrer à nouveau programmé six heures
après le lancement il y a aussi
une fenêtre tournée vers l'avant dans  le module
que l'équipage peut utiliser pour prendre des
mesures manuelles de distance et de
vitesse de rapprochement avec un télémètre laser en
cas de panne du système radar de rendez-vous
ce dernier module à l'arrière est
le module de propulsion abrite les
réservoirs de stockage d'oxygène le moteur principal l'
attitude  propulseurs de contrôle avionique et
équipements de communication et de contrôle la
partie propulsion de ce module
gère toutes les manœuvres orbitales y compris
celles nécessaires au rendez-vous avec la
station spatiale et la désorbitation brûler à
la fin de la mission de l'engin spatial
avant qu'il ne soit déployé les deux panneaux
solaires que vous voyez  elles sont repliées
contre le corps du
module de propulsion qui se sépare de  le
module de descente après la désorbitation brûle avec
le module orbital le panneau solaire s'étend sur
près de 35 pieds l'ensemble du vaisseau spatial
sert non seulement de véhicule de transport d'équipage
vers et depuis la station, mais
sert également de véhicule de retour d'urgence dans
le cas où les équipages devraient avoir  pour quitter
la station de manière
inattendue à une vue en direct du site un le
ms 11 du pad SWE tous les systèmes à la recherche vont jusqu'à
présent sur la bonne voie pour un lancement à l'heure à
5h31 heure centrale
[Musique]
un groupe de représentants de la NASA
est là  là-bas à Baïkonour prêt à
regarder le lancement à une courte
distance de la rampe de lancement pour une
mise à jour sur les activités là-bas, nous allons maintenant
voir l'officier des affaires publiques de la NASA Rob
Navy Asst Gary seulement sept semaines et demie se
sont écoulées depuis ce jour en
octobre  lorsque vous étiez ici pour la dernière fois le jour
de l'abandon du lancement de Soyouz qui a refusé aux
membres de l'équipage la possibilité d'atteindre la
Station spatiale internationale et a
déclenché une pléthore de plans de lecture par la
NASA Rose cosmos et  le reste du
partenariat international aujourd'hui au
début de ce qui devrait être un mois de décembre pour se
souvenir qu'un équipage multinational est sur le point
de reprendre avec le dernier équipage laissé pour
ramener la station à une
capacité d'équipage de six personnes pour les 17 prochains jours alors que
la station  le programme se remet sur la bonne voie
il faisait 22 degrés sous zéro Fahrenheit en
décembre 2012 lorsque Chris Hadfield s'est
lancé dans l'espace à partir d'ici la dernière
fois qu'un astronaute canadien a volé dans l'
espace
pas aussi mauvais à ce jour pour David
saint-jacques mais les températures
n'atteindront pas le point de congélation  ici en
fin d'après-midi et c'est une journée glaciale
pour le début de la
mission de six mois et demi un grand nombre de VIP et de
membres de la famille sont sur place aujourd'hui la nasa
représentée par bill Gerstenmaier l'
administrateur associé pour les
opérations d'exploration humaine Steve Jersey
l'associé de la NASA  l'administrateur et
gestionnaire du programme ISS Kirk Shireman le chef
de Rose cosmos Dmitry Rogozin est ici
et parmi les dignitaires canadiens
présents est royal  ty l'ancienne astronaute Julie
Payette est ici Son Excellence la très
honorable julie payette la gouverneure
générale du Canada la représentante vice-royale
du moniteur canadien
qui n'est autre que les fusées de la reine Elizabeth
II et la royauté dans le
désert d'Asie centrale alors que nous nous préparons pour un
lancement crucial vers la Station spatiale internationale
c'est-à-dire depuis le
cosmodrome de Baïkonour au Kazakhstan maintenant de retour
à Mission Control à Houston
qui était un officier des affaires publiques de la NASA
Rob Navy regarde le vaisseau spatial
prêt sur place l'un des
cosmodromes de Baïkonour prêt à être lancé le  temps car
il a signalé que tout semblait aller
pour un lancement à l'heure à 5 h 31.
Heure centrale encore une journée rapide là-
bas environ 24 degrés Fahrenheit un peu
moins de 4 degrés centigrades, nous
obtenons des vues en cabine, vous obtenez une
vue en direct  des astronautes à l'intérieur du
vaisseau spatial Soyouz qui est maintenant actuellement sur
la rampe de lancement sur le site un là-bas sur
le côté gauche de l'écran que vous pouvez voir
dans  le siège droit avec le drapeau américain
sur le côté gauche de son bras est l'
astronaute de la NASA et McLane au-dessus d'elle est l'
indicateur zéro g comme expliqué avant que le
dragon ne soit un c'est un bébé dragon choisi
par son fils qui est étreint par un
elfe de Noël l'un des  les deux indicateurs zéro g à
bord, vous pouvez voir oleg kononenko le
commandant soyuz effleurant quelques interrupteurs
alors qu'il subit les dernières étapes avant le
lancement à peu près huit minutes 22
secondes avant le décollage aujourd'hui, il sera
le commandant soyuz à sa gauche juste à
côté de l'écran son Canadien  L'
astronaute de l'Agence spatiale David saint-jacques son
indicateur 0g vous pouvez voir l'indicateur zéro-g
ci-dessus et mcclain
l'elfe avec le bébé dragon David st.
Jaques Indicator est un [ __ ] laveur choisi par
sa famille qui
reçoit de bons appels de Mission
Control à Moscou. Tout
semble toujours bon pour un décollage à l'heure
aujourd'hui
.  heure locale, il y aura toujours
le décollage de Soyouz pendant la
journée
ce matin Heure centrale maintenant moins de
sept minutes trente secondes du lancement
à ce moment les gyroscopes et la préparation en vol
et les enregistreurs ont été
activés nous verrons une série d'
autres jalons  alors que nous atteignons la
marque des 7 minutes, c'est là que les
opérations de pré-lancement sont terminées
[Musique]
entrez car la rougeur est d'une minute
tout se passe en premier et
nous attendrons vos pores et veuillez
activer la caméra vidéo qui se trouve
près du commandant  obtenez maintenant un autre
en vue de la cabine David saint-jacques que vous
pouvez voir à gauche voir le
[ __ ] laveur jouet indicateur zéro g au-dessus de lui choisi
par sa famille maintenant moins de sept minutes
après le lancement recevoir des appels que toutes
les opérations de pré-lancement sont terminées
tout semble bon jusqu'à présent  à ce
stade du compte à rebours, le Soyouz est le
premier et le deuxième étage des moteurs sont prêts
pour le lancement et la télémétrie a été
reçue de la fusée indiquant que
tous les systèmes principaux et de secours sont prêts
pour le lancement au moment du lancement de Soyouz
la Station spatiale internationale sera au-
dessus du centre du Kazakhstan au sud-ouest de la
capitale d'Astana à une altitude de 252
milles terrestres la station spatiale sera à 405
milles terrestres avant le lancement de Soyouz
est  chronométré avec précision pour le moment où
la rotation de la Terre placera le
cosmodrome de Baïkonour dans le plan de l'
orbite de la Station spatiale internationale
maintenant à 5 minutes 30 secondes du lancement à
nouveau d'une série de jalons suivant
les opérations de pré-lancement le prochain
sera lors du lancement  clé à insérer
il s'agit d'une véritable chambre de combustion à clé
azote d'abord
à ce moment la clé de lancement a été
insérée dans le bunker de lancement oui c'est
une vraie clé elle fait passer la
séquence de lancement en mode automatique maintenant à seulement
quatre minutes 12 secondes du lancement
à la mesure de la naissance  le système est activé
par run to command à ce moment les
systèmes embarqués ont été basculés sur le
contrôle embarqué la comm  les affichages et les commandes du poste de pilotage d'
Ander ont été
activés et les membres d'équipage
ferment leurs casques, ce qui les met sur l'
oxygène de la combinaison
maintenant à seulement trois minutes du lancement
de la pressurisation du réservoir de propulseur d'appoint
initiée à ce moment les conduites de carburant
et d'autres éléments des moteurs de fusée
sont purgés avec de l'azote  pour les
ignifuger en éliminant les vapeurs de carburant et d'
oxydant, le réservoir d'appoint est maintenant
pressurisé pour le vol, cela optimise
le débit de carburant et aide à ajouter
un support structurel à la fusée maintenant à deux
minutes de la montre
moins d'une minute pour lancer il y
aura  une série d'autres commandes, puis
vous verrez ces tours ombilicales
qui doivent commencer à se rétracter du
véhicule Soyouz avant que le véhicule de lancement ne soit
maintenant alimenté en interne, vous pouvez voir la
première séquence automatique rétractée de la tour ombilicale
lancée
la séquence automatique est lancée cette deuxième
tour maintenant  se rétractant de dix secondes à partir du
lancement, les moteurs ont démarré et sont maintenant
au niveau de poussée préliminaire
étranglement
et décollage, nous avons le décollage d'anne
mcclain pour battre saint-jacques et oleg
kononenko explosant dans le
ciel kazakh jusqu'à la Station spatiale internationale
tout semble bon jusqu'à présent bonne
performance de première étape ou utilisation
délivrant neuf cent trente mille
livres de poussée
trente secondes et  tout a toujours l'
air bien le premier étage brûlera pendant
deux minutes les deux premières minutes et six
secondes du vol est
nominal  30 secondes et c'est un
vol, tout va encore bien,
la scène brûlera à nouveau pour le FIR
jusqu'à 1 minute 58 secondes de
vol et vous verrez ces quatre
propulseurs à sangle larguer
la tour d'évacuation de 110 secondes a été
larguée et ces quatre sangle-  sur les
boosters également largués, ils ont
terminé leur travail et tomberont
à une altitude de 28  les miles
passent maintenant à une animation que vous pouvez
voir depuis la rampe de lancement en perdant de vue
le Soyouz mais en se bonifiant à partir des performances du deuxième
étage et le véhicule est stable
150 secondes après le deuxième étage de vol,
cet étage principal fonctionne toujours bien,
ce long carénage a été largué
révélant la pression en dessous  cette
deuxième étape continuera à brûler jusqu'à
quatre minutes 43 secondes après le début du vol,
tout semble bon cette deuxième
étape fournissant quelque part entre
cent soixante-dix-huit mille et
deux cent vingt-deux mille
livres de poussée
la logistique il y a 200 secondes totale
entreprise sociale seconde  étape où l'
agent Arthur copie nominalement
tout a toujours l'air bien une
minute à gauche de cette deuxième étape
en plein milieu de l'animation, vous
verrez une structure en treillis qui sera l'
endroit où la troisième étape commencera à brûler
commencer une technique de mise en scène à chaud commencer à
brûler avant  la fin de la deuxième
étape et pousser réellement cette deuxième
étape  loin
- solution politique radicale quelques secondes
dans le discours de vol vos paramètres de rôle
ou tous les partis nominaux
tout semble toujours bon environ 10
secondes de plus de la deuxième étape brûlant
282 secondes de vol et nous avons la
confirmation d'une bonne
séparation de la deuxième étape la troisième étape est allumée nous '  ll
brûle pendant environ 4 minutes et 2 secondes
fournissant 67 000 livres de copie de poussée
et nous nous débrouillons bien 310 secondes après le
début du vol le véhicule est stable
cinq minutes trente secondes après le
début du vol nous sommes dans la troisième étape maintenant
tout va toujours bien la
troisième étape  continuera à brûler jusqu'à
environ huit minutes 45 secondes après le
début du vol la deuxième tranche tout est
nominal tout est excellent à bord
des années SOI l'équipage se porte bien de
bons rapports de l'équipage à bord
ils se sentent bien alors que la troisième étape
continue à  brûler maintenant six minutes et 15
secondes dans le vol 400 secondes dans le
vol la relation est prête café
sept minutes dans le vol tout
toujours à la recherche de bonnes secondes après le début du vol, les
oppresseurs sont trois phénoménaux dans le
café et nous nous sentons bien, nous
recevons toujours de bons rapports de l'équipage,
nous nous sentons bien car nous sommes à sept minutes
trente secondes du vol, la
vitesse maintenant presque treize mille
cinq cents miles par heure une fois  la
troisième étape met le Soyouz en orbite
et le module est séparé une série de
commandes préprogrammées seront exécutées
pour préparer le Soyouz aux
opérations orbitales ces commandes stockées appelées
commandes horodatées permettent à de nombreux
systèmes Soyouz d'être automatiquement
activés par les ordinateurs de bord  à des
heures précises stockées dans ces ordinateurs
huit minutes après le début du vol,
tout a toujours l'air bien,
c'est que la troisième étape brûle jusqu'à huit
minutes 45 secondes,
vous mettez votre local pendant des centaines et
achetez la sécession de la copie silencieuse
500 secondes 8 minutes 30 secondes après
le vol toujours à la recherche  bon 15
secondes de plus jusqu'à la coupure de la troisième étape et la
séparation 520 secondes et nous h  ave
confirmation de la séparation du troisième étage le
moteur à carburant liquide unique s'est
arrêté et est tombé à une altitude de
156 milles terrestres
tout semble toujours bon le
troisième étage effectue une
manœuvre d'évitement en ouvrant une vanne dans son
réservoir d'oxygène liquide et nous avons la
confirmation de la  vaisseau spatial
séparation capsule Soyouz et équipage en toute sécurité
en orbite le vaisseau spatial exécute automatiquement
ses commandes pré-programmées pour
déployer les antennes et les panneaux solaires
va fermer notre faveur un et but
Arbor avec deux régulateurs de débit d'air
café c'est dans le mot petit 1er octobre dans les
villages de Seussville  ont été fermés et
aucun problème avec le
café du panneau indicateur et veuillez continuer page 39 oui
copier
Robo n'a pas fonctionné ou s'opposer s'opposer puis-je être d'
accord
et vous l'annulez voici un moyen de
recommencer avec votre moniteur dans la
vue de la section du véhicule bien qu'il ait été
copie initiée
oh allez oh continue sur la
commande d'activation du téléviseur envoyé copie
moniteur sont là activer le mod dynamique  e
oui
copie au travail oui Virginia feral complexe
violet prime première seconde rappelez
-vous que l'activation a confirmé la copie et
nous recevons l'image maintenant café trois
presses les réparations de copie surélevées maintenant
désactivées et nous attendons
la première série de mesures d'un
pré visuel  -la presse est désactivée pour tout
vote cérébral Genesis en 1742 zéro attente
David sept neuf merci
pour la carte SIM à Adel 1-0 c'est sept
un équipage qui travaille maintenant à travers les nombreuses
étapes - maintenant qu'ils sont à nouveau en orbite
la séparation du troisième étage et
la coupure est confirmée a également confirmé le
déploiement de l'équipage des antennes et des panneaux
solaires travaillant à travers les étapes -
après être entré dans cette première orbite pour
assurer un vol en toute sécurité vers la
Station spatiale internationale en tant que
voie rapide pour le rendez-vous en orbite, ils
arriveront dans environ six  heures ont également obtenu la
confirmation du commandant à bord de la
Station spatiale internationale Alexander
Gerst qui a pu voir le
lancement et la troisième étape sep  aration des
membres de l'équipage alors que la
Station spatiale internationale volait
juste au-dessus de la tête au-dessus du cosmodrome de Baïkonour à
peu près à ce moment-là, la
Station spatiale internationale était à 252
milles terrestres au-dessus du nord-est de la Chine maintenant
séparés par 1586 milles entre la
Station spatiale internationale et le
contrôle Soyouz de  le vaisseau spatial
continuera d'être surveillé par le contrôle de mission
à Moscou voici une vue en direct sur le balcon
leur contrôle du vaisseau spatial sera
supervisé par ce centre juste à l'extérieur de
Moscou et les inhibiteurs confirmés seront
terminés à 1450 pour renverser le prochain de
compassion 3 1603 1603  et ce sera
fini à 16h20 et nous allons activer
et désactiver l'accès manuellement copier
je confirme l'activation d'un et une
chose est une grande anomalie dans la classe suivante
nous allons faire un contrôle manuel
vérifions et manœuvre rapide ok  sur l'
écran vous avez sélectionné copiez-moi pour faire
greenatopia Pico et l'heure de la prochaine
orbite est la suivante
16:06 0 0 à 116 316 corriger un  d ceci est le
café de la page 25 et un grand lancement d'un
McLane David saint-jacques et oleg
kononenko qui sont maintenant dans leur
orbite préliminaire en passant par certaines
des étapes pour se rendre au
complexe orbital dans seulement six heures
pour des orbites autour du  terre, le décollage
était juste à l'heure 5 h 31, heure centrale,
nous attendrons certaines de ces
rediffusions de lancement et les moyens pour lesquels
nous répondons aux questions en utilisant le hashtag
demandent à la NASA sur Twitter, nous en avons eu quelques-uns
pendant l'émission d'aujourd'hui celui-ci vient
de Tran situ demandant comment le
calendrier opérationnel de la station spatiale internationale a été modifié depuis
l'incident d'octobre et quand, alors que l'
équipage actuel s'attendait à revenir sur Terre, de
nombreuses opérations se sont produites depuis
qu'alexey ovchinin de ross cosmos et nick
hague de la nasa ont interrompu leur ascension vers
le  Station spatiale internationale
le 11 octobre, il y a eu des
enquêtes et une collaboration entre
Rose cosmos et la NASA pour modifier
un peu le calendrier si vous prenez des
toilettes  k à la Station spatiale internationale en
ce moment, il y a en fait quatre
véhicules de visite actuellement attachés à la
Station spatiale internationale, dont deux
sont le véhicule de progression russe qui
transporte les fournitures d'équipage ainsi que le
Northrop Grumman Cygnus 10 qui est
actuellement attaché au port nadir ou à
la terre  -côté face au module d'unité,
vous pouvez également y voir le Soyouz
MSO neuf qui transportait l'
équipage actuel à bord d'un Serina et le
chancelier Alexander Gerst et Sergei
Prokofiev, un grand nombre de ces lancements ont
été déplacés pour assurer la
livraison en toute sécurité et  poursuite de l'
habitation continue de la Station spatiale internationale
l'équipage qui vient de lancer aujourd'hui
devrait également accoster aujourd'hui 3 décembre il y
aura six membres d'équipage à bord de la
Station spatiale internationale jusqu'à l'
équipage du MSO neuf que vous venez de
revoir là-bassur le chancelier Gerst
et Prokofiev sont sur le point de partir le
19 décembre u.s.  le 20 décembre au
Kazakhstan,
nous avons une autre question d'Edie sur
qui demande pourquoi la NASA utilise toujours
le cosmodrome de Baïkonour au Kazakhstan
pour le lancement vers la
Station spatiale internationale, le véhicule Soyouz que nous
venons de voir lancé aujourd'hui est actuellement le
seul véhicule classé humain qui  peut
assurer le transport de la Terre à la
Station spatiale internationale, ce qui est vrai
maintenant devenu 2019, nous commencerons à examiner
certains lancements d'équipages commerciaux en commençant
par quelques missions de test en commençant par
le dragon de l'équipage SpaceX et bien sûr la
Boeing Star Line est sur le point de mener une
série  de missions de tests dont certaines
incluent l'envoi d'équipage à la
Station spatiale internationale et encore une fois nous
pouvons commencer à attendre avec impatience
les capteurs thermiques de l'année prochaine à l'
heure spécifiée copie
je suis désolé femme je suis désolé et les paramètres orbitaux que
vous connaissez ainsi que 18  : 27 l'
inclinaison est de 51,6 en recevant de bonnes
questions du hashtag en tant que NASA alors que nous
attendons que certaines de ces rediffusions arrivent
en vous  peut voir le lancement de l'équipage MS 11 se
lancer à nouveau, mais en
attendant, continuez à envoyer ces bonnes
questions en utilisant le hashtag a demandé à la NASA
celui-ci vient de Terry combien de temps
cela prend-il entre le moment du lancement et l'embarquement dans la
Station spatiale internationale, vous pouvez
vérifier que  aujourd'hui encore, le lancement a eu lieu à
5 h 31, heure centrale, notre couverture
pour l'amarrage de ce véhicule à la
Station spatiale internationale commencera
à 10 h 30, heure centrale, à la recherche d'un
rendez-vous de 6 heures à la station à
11 h 36, heure centrale, donc  nous les utilisons,
il est 11h00, nous allons nous amarrer au module poisk
qui se trouve du côté de l'espace
peu de temps après, nous ferons une petite pause
puis nous reviendrons à 12h30.
Heure centrale pour commencer l'ouverture de l'écoutille
et la couverture de la cérémonie d'accueil. L'
heure d'ouverture de l'écoutille est prévue pour environ
13 h 35.  Heure centrale donc quand tout est
dit et fait, vous regardez environ
huit heures entre le moment du lancement et
le moment de l'ouverture de la trappe et de l'
entrée dans la Station spatiale internationale
[Musique]
à 1450 68 le faire dans l'attitude est
confirmé
et un de plus  question
de Sakura qui demande combien de temps
il faut pour terminer toute la
formation nécessaire à la vie à bord de la
Station spatiale internationale, nous prendrons
par exemple une McLain qui a été sélectionnée
comme astronaute en 2013, elle était
candidate astronaute pour les premiers
années de formation en passant par certaines de
ces étapes de formation préliminaires comme l'
apprentissage des systèmes de la Station spatiale internationale
, certaines techniques de marche dans l'espace, la
formation en milieu sauvage et en survie et la
formation t-38 qui prend environ deux ans,
elle a terminé cette formation en juillet
2015, elle est la première astronaute de  la
classe 2013 à se diriger vers la
Station spatiale internationale et cela
vient un peu plus de trois ans après
avoir terminé son astronaute
formation des candidats
vous regardez la dernière étape de notre
couverture pour le lancement de l'équipage de l'
expédition 58 à bord du
vaisseau spatial MS 11 Soyuz composé de gauche à
droite dans le graphique inférieur là d'un
McLane de la NASA oleg kononenko de ros
cosmos et David saint-  jacques de l'
Agence spatiale canadienne a lancé à l'heure
aujourd'hui à 5 h 31. L'heure centrale avait un
lancement de manuel une insertion en orbite
sont maintenant en route vers la
Station spatiale internationale à la recherche d'
un rendez-vous à quatre orbites cela prend environ
six heures
vue du balcon de  Centre de contrôle de mission
à Korolev juste à l'extérieur de Moscou,
nous sommes à la dernière étape de notre
couverture de lancement pour aujourd'hui un lancement à l'heure à
5 h 31, heure centrale, un van McClane
David saint-jacques et Oleg Kononenko
actuellement en orbite et sur  en route vers
la Station spatiale internationale en
attendant quelques rediffusions de lancement, vous pouvez revoir le
lancement, mais en attendant,
continuez à envoyer des questions en utilisant le
hashtag ask NASA we have  un de la rangée
Heat qui demande si l'
équipage de l'expédition 57 du président est revenu sur Terre sur
ce même MS 11 le 19 décembre, l'
équipage du MS 11 le fera une fois arrivé à
la Station spatiale internationale bien qu'il soit
amarré au module poisk c'est sur
le côté face à l'espace  si
vous regardiez la Station spatiale internationale à l'
endroit, ce serait
en haut, ces trois membres d'équipage
emmèneraient leur vaisseau vers et depuis la
Station spatiale internationale, l'équipage actuel à
bord maintenant de Syrena et le chancelier
Sergei Prokofiev et alexander gerst le
feront  prenez le Soyuz MSO neuf actuellement
sur le Ross ce module que vous pouvez voir
là sur ce graphique il y a
cinq véhicules en visite que vous pouvez voir sur
le graphique Soyuz ms 11 en haut
ils sont actuellement en route vers la
Station spatiale internationale mais  l'
équipage actuel ramènera le Soyouz MSO
neuf à la maison le 19 décembre u.s.  fois que nous
avons une autre
question de Josh Watt qui demande si
quelque chose ne va pas pendant l'amarrage, que
peut faire l'équipage de la Station spatiale internationale en
ce moment, le véhicule Soyouz
communique avec certaines des
stations au sol pour d'autres
stations au sol russes et passera au
Les satellites de suivi et de relais de données des TDR alors qu'ils orbitent autour de
la Terre actuellement le
Soyouz et la Station spatiale internationale au-
dessus de l'océan Pacifique
une fois que le Soyouz se rapproche un peu
de la Station spatiale internationale très
près de l'heure d'amarrage, il
pourra en fait communiquer avec  la
Station spatiale internationale si quelque chose
devait mal tourner, l'équipage de la
Station spatiale internationale du
côté russe de la station spatiale peut en
fait prendre le contrôle à distance du
véhicule Soyouz
une autre question appropriée venant de
Katy demandant comment les astronautes de la
Station spatiale internationale dépensent
vacances dans l'espace bien sûr début
décembre les premières vacances à venir fo  r
l'équipage sera Noël actuellement à
bord du Soyouz en tant qu'indicateur 0g l'
elfe sur l'étagère
étreignant actuellement le bébé dragon c'était
un indicateur qu'une fois Internet le
Soyouz a été inséré dans une orbite
autour de la terre qui
indiquerait qu'ils étaient en fait  dans l'
environnement de microgravité, l'équipage veut
à bord d'un amarrage dans six heures à peine
avoir déjà beaucoup de ses
articles de vacances à bord, mais quelques autres, y compris de la
nourriture, seront en route vers la
Station spatiale internationale à partir de
demain, le spacex CRS 16 est
devrait décoller de la station de l'armée de l'
air de Cap Canaveral en Floride demain à
bord sera une partie de la nourriture de vacances,
y compris des aliments frais qui seront
livrés à la Station spatiale internationale
lors d'un rendez-vous de deux jours arrivant à
peine deux jours plus tard le 6 décembre à
nouveau  nous avons eu un grand décollage aujourd'hui d'un
McLean deux pieds saint-jacques et Oleg
Kononenko actuellement en orbite au-dessus de l'
océan Pacifique pourchassant l'
Inte  Station spatiale nationale sur un
rendez-vous à quatre orbites, nous avons quelques rediffusions
pour vous afin que vous puissiez assister à nouveau à ce lancement de
ce lancement de manuel que nous venons de
voir il y a 30 minutes
[Musique]